no way
this is Modern Warfare Ukrainian style
it might look like a video game in fact
it is made by a Ukrainian gaming company
but it's serious business since July
Ukraine's military has started setting
up arcade style centers to train its
troops soon they hope to have a virtual
Training Center like this in every
Brigade a lot of shooting ranges have
been targeted by Russian Rockets
so and these are very mobile you can set
them up in any room or underground
facility and it's a lot cheaper this
next Generation light anti-tank weapon
for example costs more than thirty
thousand dollars and it's a single use
item use it once and it's finished
when I was training it I it took me four
shots to finally start getting into the
target which is a lot of money it's not
just expensive Ukraine's Army doesn't
have that kind of ammunition to spare so
more time on this range means more
accuracy downrange
weapons designed to take out large
targets like this tank are often
expensive and require a lot of space to
fire so laser training makes sense but
when it comes to Urban combat with
close-up Small Arms fire there's really
no substitute for the real thing live
fire on a shooting range
these Ukrainian territorial Defense
Force soldiers are aiming for constant
Improvement
we have a very high motivation this is
volunteers all of them and this is not a
conscript like taken from the street but
Ross is a everyone came here on the
Goodwill to protect our homeland
they are battle hardened having proved
themselves against the Russian army here
in Kiev and in the russian-occupied
Eastern Ukrainian provinces of luhan's
condone yet for some of them it may be
hard especially when they come back here
to the Civil Life
but there they all
mobilize it we can mobilize it they
perform well yeah they perform well and
they know that they have to do this work
these civilian soldiers are finishing
this work so they can return home to
their regular work John hendron Al
Jazeera Kiev